Republican congresswoman Kat kamik of
Florida member of the energy committee
and the subcommittee on the
weaponization of the federal government
is in Focus now uh congresswoman what is
your initial reaction to this
Harris it's outrage you know before they
were sacrificing children's education
and their safety in New York City at the
behest of these illegals they were
pushing our homeless veterans out to
make room for these illegals that have
been shipped in busting but you've heard
me say it before and I'll say it again
you play stupid games you win stupid
prizes and as a sanctuary City New York
has made their bed they now have to
contend with the fact that they have
between 750 to 1500 illegals coming to
their City every single day not only
that but 65 percent of the illegals that
they are housing and taking care of are
on the public Dole that means their food
their housing their health care and
Beyond and it is all at the expense of
our kids and our veterans so this is
this is really starting to hit close to
home for so many people and if there is
not a consequence for these illegals
coming in it'll just continue well I
just remember when he was running mayor
Adams in New York City had wanted there
to be some voting allowances for people
who were not citizens so I I don't know
how shocked everybody can be that now
that the sanctuary city is an actual
Sanctuary that he wouldn't welcome it
but I guess we should be shocked I don't
know
well that's the thing when you look at
last Congress hr1 the for the
politicians act that was Nancy Pelosi's
signature piece of legislation that
would have not only nationalized our
elections but would have allowed
non-citizens to vote so it doesn't take
a genius to to put two and two together
here where you have non-citizens being
allowed to vote and then you have an
open border it seems to me that the left
will do anything to win an election even
at the expense of National Security
certainly at the expense of our kids and
as I said we've seen homeless veterans
getting booted out of hotels and and
Facilities to make way for these
illegals that have been that was shifter
day yes that was just yesterday
today is public
as public kids in New
York all right members of Chicago's
black community rallied Friday and went
after city leaders for opening up police
stations and other abandoned schools to
house illegal immigrants watch
our specific frustration lies in the
continuous and blatant disregard for the
safety and overall quality of life of
black residents a couple of my
participants that's what we called and
we don't call them Defenders they are
homeless when I went about inquiring
about some housing one of my
participants
reached me on my phone after I was
including Mr Carrington uh I did get
placed on the waitlist but I was told
that the immigrants were taking priority
all right let me get this straight
so now we can add to U.S military
veterans displaced for illegal
immigrants public school children put in
a way that is unsafe for them so parents
are taking them out of school they're
displaced by illegal immigrants and now
black residents are concerned about the
homeless in Chicago being displaced by
illegal residents this is just wild
hairs and I'm so glad that you mentioned
what's happening in New York they are
actually using one of the former
training academies for the NYPD to house
these folks but it gets better they
still have an active range where they do
target practice that is in use that is
also housing illegals does anyone see a
problem with this I mean this is absurd
I I feel like I'm taking crazy pills
when I'm reading these stories and
hearing from our border patrol agents
who by the way are exhausted I got a
text from one today and said there have
to be consequences if we're gonna stem
the flow we can't maintain this we're
exhausted and we're terrified for our
families we can't do our jobs help us
please congresswoman forgive me I'm
going to interject here because I want
to I want to fact check now are they
still at the border working that seven
day rotation no time off yes yes and and
I'm telling you right now in California
and in Arizona those sectors are getting
hit the hardest
um I think Texas the state of Texas has
stepped up as much as they possibly can
to give reinforcements through Texas DPS
but in Arizona and California they are
struggling and they are terrified for
their communities and they are
overworked underpaid and unappreciated I
am deeply concerned about the fact that
we have seen not only a Pakistani
individual a foreign National on the
international terrorist watch list who
was apprehended but also in California
an Afghan National on the terrorist
watch list that was apprehended you know
as well as anyone how many hundreds of
thousands of godaways are now in our
country that have criminal pass and
intentions this is scary stuff I have
told border patrol leadership on this
very program in the last few days how
much we pray for them we are with them
but you know what they need they need
some rest because if they're going to
catch terrorists I mean can you imagine
how critical that job is to all of us
our sovereignty at stake here we've got
to make sure that they feel whole and
appreciated congresswoman thank you
always for being in Focus thank you
Harris have a great week I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis